[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تتهم اوكرانيا
بمحاوله استهداف مقاطعتين روسيتين
بالمسيرات ليلا
المانيا تؤكد قلقها من برنامج ايران
النووي وتؤكد انها لا ترى مبررا لنسبه
التخصيب الحاليه
الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه تعلن اكتمال
مشروع لتصنيع الزوارق الاعتراضيه السريعه
ونناقش في الرابعه كذلك
جامعه كاوست السعوديه تطلق اكبر مبادره
لاحياء الشعب المرجانيه في العالم
العربيه تتجول في اول متحف لتاريخ الطب في
السعوديه وتستعرض ابرز اقسامه
حياكم الله اقر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بان العام الماضي كان صعبا مشيرا
الى ان وكاله الامن الروسيه نجحت في احباط
مخططات ارهابيه تستهدف الامن القومي
الروسي وقال بوتين خلال زيارته لمقر الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي ان اوكرانيا تستخدم
اساليب ارهابيه ولها تاريخ طويل في ذلك
ووجه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين وكاله الامن
بالعمل سريعا في المناطق الجديده التي
سيطرت عليها روسيا في اوكرانيا والرد على
التهديدات بكل الوسائل كما شدد الرئيس
الروسي على اهميه مواصله دعم القوات هناك
بكل الاسلحه والذخائر وتقويه وحدات
الاستطلاع
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في بيان لها
ان قواتها اسقطت الطائرتين اوكرانيتين
بدون طيار حول استهداف البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه داخل البلاد في منطقه كولومنا
الحضاريه والاخرى جنوبا قرب منطقه
كراسوندار ووفق بيان الوزاره فان الجيش
الروسي تصدى للطائرتين الانتحاريتين مشيرا
الى ان حادثتي اسقاطها لم تسفر عن اي
اصابات او دمار وفي هذا الشان اكدت ان
السلطات المختصه تواصل اجراء تحقيقات في
الوضع
وبانها مطمئنه وان لا شيء يهدد سلامه
السكان
اعلن الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين تلقى تقريرا حول تعليق المجال الجوي
في سان بطرسبرج دون الافصاح عن مزيد من
التفاصيل في الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان مقاتلات الدفاع الجوي اجرت
مناورات للتعامل مع اهداف جويه افتراضيه
في المنطقه العسكريه الغربيه وجاء ذلك
تزامنا مع اعاده السلطات الروسيه فتح
المجال الجوي فوق مدينه سان بطرسبرج
الروسيه بعد اغلاقها مؤقتا وذلك بعد رصد
تحليق جسم غير معروف في السماء واقلاع
طائرات مقاتله الاستطلاع واشار موقع
فلايرا دار الى ان عددا من الرحلات
الداخليه المتجهه الى مدينه سانت بطرسبرج
عادت الى محل اقلاعها
قال قائد قوات الحمايه الاشعاعيه
والكيميائيه والبيولوجيه في الجيش الروسي
ايغور كيليليوف ان قوته رصد التقدم
ومدرعات امريكيه الصنع تحوي مواد كيميائيه
نحو خطوط التماسي في اوكرانيا وخلال مؤتمر
الصحفي اشار كيريوف الى نيه امريكا القيام
باستفزازات كيميائيه
في الثاني والعشرين من فبراير اعقدت منظمه
غير حكوميه امريكيه مؤتمرا حول الاحداث في
اوكرانيا وفي حديثه قال السفير الامريكي
السابق في روسيا
ان موسكو تخطط لنشر اسلحه كيميائيه في
منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه نحن نعتبر
هذه المعلومات على انها نيه للولايات
المتحده والمتواطئين معها للقيام باستفزاز
في اوكرانيا باستخدام مواد كيميائيه سامه
نحذر من انه في حاله حدوث اي استفزاز لنشي
مواد كيميائيه سامه فسنحدد الجنات
الحقيقيين من اجل المعقبه
شدد الكرملين على اهميه مراعاه الحقائق
الاقليميه الجديده ودستور روسيا الاتحاديه
فيما يتعلق بامكانيات ابرام معاهده سلام
مع اوكرانيا مضيفا انه لا توجد اشارات من
الجانب الاوكراني حول الاستعداد للمفاوضات
مع روسيا في الوقت ذاته اشار الكريملين
الى امكانيه تسويه الوضع في اوكرانيا من
خلال المفاوضات لكنه اعطى الاولويه لتحقيق
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الى هناك مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم كاتيا
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معنا في نشاط الرابعه
من الرياض قبل قليل كان هناك حديث للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الحديث كان منذ
الصباح عن اغلاق الاجواء في سان بطرسبرج
لكن حديث الرئيس بوتين في هذا في هذا
الخطاب كان مختلفا ما ابرز ما قاله لماذا
لم يتحدث كذلك عن قضيه
مرحبا نايف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اليوم هو تحدث خلال اجتماعهم مع اعضاء
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي هذا الاجتماع
الذي لم يعقد منذ عام 2000 2021 طبعا هذا
الاجتماع الاول بعد البدء روسيا للعمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا واهميته تكمن بسبب
طبعا اهميه عمل هذا الجهاز وهو تحدث واهم
تحدث عنه خلال هذا الاجتماع هو اهميه
مواجهه
استخبارات الغربيه التي كثفت عملها كما
قال الرئيس الروسي وتحدث عن اهميه تعزيز
الحدود مع الجانب الاوكراني لصد اي هجوم
من قبل جماعات التخريبيه وايضا تحدث عن
اهميه دعم الفضاء الرقمي في روسيا بسبب
ايضا في ضوء الهجمات المكثفه الاسبرانيه
التي تتعرض لها روسيا طبعا الرئيس الروسي
لم يتطرق الى موضوع اغ المجال الجوي فوق
مدينه بطرسبورغ كما تحدث الكرملين هو على
علم كامل بالوضع هناك ولكن لم يتم الكشف
حتى الان عن ملابسات هذا الوضع ولم يتم
الاعلام من قبل وزاره الدفاع عن اسباب
اغلاق المجال الجوي فوق مدينه بطرس يعني
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتكشف اي معلومات اي
تفاصيل حول ما حدث في سماء سام بطرسبرج
هذا اليوم ولا معلومات مؤكده قريبا بان
الكريم
حتى وان كان تحديث صحفيه
صحيح نايف لم يكشف الكريم ولم يتحدث فيما
اذا كان هناك اعلانات ستكون او بيانات
لاحقه له ولكن
السؤال تم توجيهه من قبل الى وزاره الدفاع
بما انها هي المسؤوله عن الوضع ايضا
الامني وتم رفع
طائرات الى الى السماء من اجل الجسم الذي
تحدثت عنه وسائل الاعلام الروسيه وجسم
غريب كان في سماء مدينه بوتسبورغ ادى الى
اغلاق المجال الجوي وايقاف حركه الطيران
التي تم فتحها فيما بعد ولكن حتى الان
ننتظر تفسير من قبل وزاره الدفاع او
الجهات ايضا الاخرى من قبل اداره الطيران
هنا في روسيا المسؤوله عن المجال الجوي
فوق مدينه
لمعرفه ملابسات هذا الحادث واسباب ايقاف
الطيران او الرحلات الجويه هناك بالحديث
عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في الملف الذي
كنا بدانا في هذه النشره واعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين
ليلا كانت تستهدف منطقه كولومنا وكذلك
منطقه
كراسوندار اذا يعني كان الاسم صحيحا لهذه
المنطقه ماذا لديك من معلومات كافيه
بالفعل تم الحديث عن صدد مسيرات كانت
اخترقت الحدود والاراضي الروسيه في مدينه
كريسندار وفي ايضا مدينه اخرى هي تقع في
ضواحي روسيا كما تحدث عمده العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو انه لم يسقط اي ضحايا نتيجه
اسقاط المسيره التي اخترقت الاراضي
الروسيه طبعا هي كما تعتبر هي مسيرات
اوكرانيه قامت باختراق الاراضي الروسيه لم
يصب احد باذى هي فقط تم اسقاطها بالقرب من
محطه للغاز في ضواحي روسيا وفي كريسندار
استطاعت القوات الروسيه من اسقاطها
وطبعا هذا هو ليس هذا الحادث الاول من
نوعه اختراق المسير المسيرات الاوكرانيه
للاراضي الروسيه كنا قد شهدنا مرارا
عمليات اختراق من قبل مسيرات الروسيه
للاراضي عفوا مسارات اوكرانيا من الاراضي
الروسيه وتم صدها ايضا من قبل نظام الدفاع
الجوي الروسي نا يف اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
موسكو مراسله العربيه على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
في التطورات الميدانيه مشاهدينا للازمه
الاوكرانيه كدا الجيش الاوكراني ان روسيا
تركز هجماتها في شرق خار كيف وباخمت مشيرا
الى انه احبط ستين هجوم الروسيا خلال 24
ساعه قبل ذلك قال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه والاكسندر سيريسكي ان الوضع في
محيط مدينه اصبح متوترا للغايه وفي رساله
على تيليجرام اوضح الجنرال الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه دفعت بوحدات هجوميه تابعه
لمجموعات فاجنر العسكريه في محاوله
لاختراق دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني بهدف فرض
حصار على المدينه
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
رائد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي بنشره
الرابعه من الرياض رائد كنت معي اليوم
تتحدث عن تطويق يعني شبه كامل او بشكل
الهلال على هذه المدينه التي تتركز فيها
طبعا المعارك منذ اكثر من شهرين في باقمت
هل باتت قاب قوسين او ادنى من ان تسقط
طباخ مت
مساء الخير نايف بالفعل المعارك الاكثر
سخونه هي في مدينه باخمت ما زالت القوات
الروسيه او قوات فاجنر تحديدا تحاول
اقتحام اراضي اكثر في هذه المدينه من جميع
النواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه لكن
لنعرج قليلا على الموقع الذي نقف فيه صدفه
نايف هنا يعني وجدنا بان هذا مكان لقذيفه
سقطت واستهدفت طفل في هذا المكان سنتحدث
عن باخمه والصوره يعني تسلط الضوء على هذا
الموقع الذي صادفناه نايف بالفعل المحاور
ساخره ساخنه جدا في هذا يعني في هذه
المدينه باخموت حيث ما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تدافع عن المدينه بشراسه تتقدم
قوات فاغنر من الناحيه الشماليه من مدينه
ياجد نايا تحديدا التي سيطرت عليها في
اليومين الماضيين وتحاول
الوصول الى مدينه بغدانا فهي تعتبر في
المحور الغربي ويسعى الجيش الروسي او
القوات الخاصه لاكمال الطوقهم يعني اصبحوا
يشكلون طوق باكثر من هلال حتى نايف
الذي يريد ان يصل له الجيش الروسي هو قطع
الامدادات العسكريه من الناحيه الغربيه
بلده بغداد تقع ناحيه الغربيه واذا وصل
لها الجيش الروسي فهذا يعني انه قاب قوسين
او ادنى كما اسلفنا من السيطره الكامله
على تطويق المدينه ويبقى المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين الذين ستنقطع عنهم الامدادات
بالفعل دخلت القوات الروسيه او قوات باجنر
من جميع النواحي كيلومترات معدوده يوم امس
شهد تقدم لقوات فاغنر في
حي يدعى ستوبينكا وهذا الحي يعني اظهرت
صور وفيديوهات للقوات الروسيه وهي
تتحرك وتتقدم في هذا المحور كما ان
المحورين الشرقي والجنوب ايضا دخل منهما
الجيش الروسي واظهرت الفيديوهات تصريحات
يعني للجنرالات الروسيه وهم يقولون بان
مركز المدينه بعيد باقل من كيلومترين
دينيس موشيلين القائم باعمال المقاطعه هنا
طرف روسيا قال اليوم في تصريح له بان
المعارك ايضا تحتدم في محوري مارنكا
تشهد يعني هجوم عنيف من قبل القوات
الروسيه ويعني تكاد القوات الروسيه ان
تبدا باقتحام المدينه حتى الان ما زالت
القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم ولم يتم اقتحام
المدينه او الدخول اليها لكن مدينه مارنكا
اشار دينيس بوشيلين الى ان السيطره عليها
بالكامل لان الصراع على الثلث الاخير منها
سيطره القوات الروسيه على ثلثي المدينه
والص الثلث الاخير قال دينيس بوشن بان
البطء بالسيطره على الجزء الاخير منها
يرجع الى ان هناك امدادات عسكريه بشريه
وبالذخيره لمارينكا وهذا ما ابطا السيطره
الكامله نعم بهكذا طوقوا بهكذا شكل على
على على باخم وترائد هل يمكن القول بان
قوات فاجنر شبه الرسميه اصبحت يعني اقرب
الى مركز المدينه يعني نتحدث عن اثنين
كيلو او اقل من اثنين كيلو الى داخل هذه
المدينه نحن نعلم انها مدينه صغيره
بالاساس وبالاصل لكنها استراتيجيه
بالفعل
بالفعل اقل من كيلو مترين وربما تصبح اقل
بكثير لان القوات ما زالت تتقدم ورغم
مقاومه الجيش الاوكراني لكنها تتقدم من
جميع النواحي حتى تصل الى وسط او قلب
المدينه يبقى دائما الجزء الغربي الجزء
الغربي الذي يكون دائما اكثر تحصينا حيث
صلته بالامدادات العسكريه من الغرب ربما
تطول مده يعني السيطره على الجزء الغربي
لان
القوات الاوكرانيه ستكون يعني محصنه بشكل
جيد في هذا الجزء لكن الايام القليله
المقبله ستظهر لنا التطورات وهل سيتم
الطوق باكمل ام سيبقى من حول المدينه ما
عدا الناحيه الغربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل الصوره التي
نقلتها لنا من دانكس مورس العربيه رائد
الاخضر
اكد الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينسى
السلطان ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا في الحلف
على المد الطويل لكنه شدد في مؤتمر الصحفي
مع رئيسه وزراء فنلندا على ان القضيه
العاجله هي حمايه دول الجناح الشرقي من
الهجمات الروسيه وقال السولتين بيرج ان
اعضاء حلف الناتو اتفقوا على ان اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا في وقت ما
وصف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد
برايس تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين امير عبداللهيان بشان ارسال واشنطن
رسائل لايران عبر العراق حول الاتفاق
النووي بانها كاذبه وقال نيد برايس لوكاله
ايران انترناشونال ان المسؤولين
الايرانيين فقط هم من يستطيعون تفسير سبب
استمرارهم في قول هذه الاكاذيب مشيرا الى
ان احياء الاتفاق النووي لم يكن مطروحا
على جدول الاعمال منذ اشهر ولم يتم ارسال
اي رساله لطهران اضاف برايس ان النظام
الايراني مستمر في قول الاكاذيب لخداع
بقيه العالم وان المزاعم الايرانيه بشان
الاتفاق النووي لن تغير الحقائق المتعلقه
به
قالت وزيره خارجيه المانيا انا لينا
بيربوك انه لا تبرير منطقي من الناحيه
المدنيه لاحداث تخصيب ايراني لليورانيوم
بنسبه 83
وخلال مؤتمر الصحفي في برلين مع نظيرها
الاسرائيلي ايليكوين شددت على ضروره منع
طهران من امتلاك قنبله نوويه معربه عن
قلقها من البرنامج النووي الايراني وبدوره
اكد وزير خارجيه اسرائيل على ضروره ابقاء
خيار الحل العسكري ضد ايران على الطاوله
معتبرا ان هناك خيارين بشان ايران اما
تشديد العقوبات او الحل العسكري واضاف
كوين ان السبب او السبيل الوحيد لوقف
التقدم النووي الايراني هو عبر الضغط
الدبلوماسي والاقتصادي واوضح انه طلب من
المانيا تصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني
كمنظمه ارهابيه
السبيل الوحيد لوقف التقدم النووي
الايراني هو عبر الضغط الدبلوماسي
والاقتصادي المجتمع الدولي لا يجب ان يقبل
ابدا برنامج ايران النووي ويجب اجبارها
على الوفاء بالتزاماتها الدوليه وفقا
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه حان الوقت
لاتخاذ خطوات وافعال لمنع ايران من امتلاك
سلاح النووي كما طلبت من نظيره الالمانيه
تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه في
المانيا وتوسيع ذلك ليشمل اوروبا
من باريس ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي ناصر
زهير سيدنا ناصر مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض اولا في اي
سياق يمكن ان نفهم هذه
التصريحات هذا الموقف الالماني شديد القلق
من البرنامج النووي الايراني
تحياتي لك عزيزي ولفريق العمل يعني
التصحيحات الالمانيه الان تفسر تغير موقف
الالماني الذي كانت دائما قريب نوعا ما
للمرونه مع ايران ولا يكون هناك موقف
اوروبي متشدد وكان يقول بان التصريحات
الايرانيه التي تقول بانها لا تسعى
الامتلاك السلاح النووي نوعا ما هي مقبوله
ولكن الان وفق المتغيرات الاساسيه التي
طرات على العلاقه بين ايران والاتحاد
الاوروبي تصرفات ايران ايضا التي بدات
تشكك بشكل فعلي في برنامجها النووي وما هي
مالته غيرت الموقف الالماني وتاتي هذه
التصريحات لتقول بان هذا الموقف فعليا
تغير بشكل حقيقي ايضا جمله لافته اتت في
تصريحات عندما قالت بانه لا تفسير
ايرانهم تخصيب ايران اليورانيوم بنسبه 83%
وان تصرفات ايران تزعزع استقرار في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ما جماعاتها المواليه لها او
الميليشياتها المواليه لها يعني الان اصبح
هناك ربط دائما ما كان يتم الدفع اليه من
قبل المشككين في سياسات ايران ومدى
التزامها في هذا الاطار بعدم زعزعه
الاستقرار في المنطقه وبالتالي ربط
البرنامج النووي وتقدم ايران بجماعاتها
ومليشياتها هذه هي نقطه مهمه هل نحن ايضا
كذلك على موعد معاد تشدد مواقف لدول اخرى
كانت من ضمن الدول التي وقعت مع ايران على
الاتفاق النووي السابق
يعني لا يمكن ان نقول بانه هناك دول اخرى
ستتشدد لانها دول الاساسيه التي ستغير
مواقفها كانت فرنسا والمانيا هذه الدول
التي كانت نوعا ما متفهمه يقول تريد ان
تبقي ايران كما كانت تقول داخل الحظيره
النوويه ولا يكون هناك تشدد اكثر موقف
الفرنسي تغير وبشكل جذري لعده قضايا
تحدثنا عنها سابقا اهمها ما تقوم به ايران
من تصرفات حتى مع الاوروبيين عبر قضايا
الاوروبيين المحتجزين في ايران وما تسميها
الدول الاوروبيه بعمليات اختطاف او ابتزاز
والنقطه الثانيه المانيا الان التي بدا
فعليا موقفها ايضا يتغير بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده موقفهم معروف تبقى
لدينا الصين وروسيا الصين وروسيا لن
يغيروا من موقفهم ليس بسبب تصرفات ايران
او تقييم تصرفات ايران بالالتزام بالاتفاق
نووي من عدمه بل بسبب مصالح اخرى الاتفاق
الاستراتيجي بين الصين وايران وايضا حاجه
روسيا لايران في مرحله وربما ايضا حاله
حتى
الاستفاف والاستقطاب طبعا
الحاليه بين المعسكرين الشرقي والغربي
ربما يدفعها يعني عدم الوقوف مع الولايات
المتحده في هذا الموقف لكن ايضا وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي كان له موقف اخر ملفت
وطلب من نظيرته في الخارجيه الالمانيه
تصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه ارهابيه برايك
هل يمكن ان تستجيب المانيا لهذا الطلب في
ضوء ما تقدم من موقفها القلق المتشدد تجاه
ايران في التخصيب تقسيط بالجرانيوم او
ايضا حتى في سياساتها في زعزعه امن
واستقرار دول المنطقه
من الصعب على المانيا ان تقوم بهذه الخطوه
بمعزل عن بروكسل يعني بمعنى ان مثل هذا
القرار يجب ان يكون قرار اوروبي شامل من
الدول الاوروبيه جميعها ايضا التوجه
لتصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه ارهابيه هو
ليس بسبب طلب وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي او
ما صرح به في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي بل ايضا
هي طرحت القضيه في بروكسل منذ اسابيع وكان
هناك تصويت ايضا او طلب من البرلمان
الاوروبي على تصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه
ارهابيه ولكن المانيا بدات فعليا وبشكل
حقيقي بالتشدد تجاه المنظمات والهيئات
التي تتبع للحرس الثوري الايراني كما كان
الحال مع حزب الله سابقا على سبيل المثال
عندما ايضا تم تصنيف الجناحين السياسي
والعسكري كمنظمه ارهابيه والمنظمات التي
تتبع لهم الان سيكون هناك تغيير وبدا هذا
التغيير بشكل فعلي منذ اشهر في السياسه
الالمانيه والسياسه الاوروبيه مثل النمسا
على سبيل المثال التي كانت تتساهل مع اذرع
الحرس الثوري الموجوده في اوروبا وكان
اذرع اقتصاديه وازرع سياسيه او اذرو حتى
ميليشياويه تقوم بعمليات التجنيد او
النشاطات الحرس الثوري والمليشيات التابعه
لهذه النقطه بدات فعليا بالتغيير ولكن على
الموقف الرسمي تصنيف الحرس دوري كمنظمه
ارهابيه يتطلب قرار من بروكسل هذا القرار
الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يوجد ما عليه شكر
جزيل من باريس انضم الينا المحلل السياسي
ناصر زهير شكرا جزيلا لك
رابعه مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه تعلن اكتمال
مشروع لتصنيع الزوارق الاعتراضيه السريعه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع والهيئه العامه للصناعات
العسكريه عن الانتهاء من مشروع تصنيع
وتوطين الزوارق الاعتراضيه السريعه من نوع
32 وفق احداث المواصفات العالميه والتي
تهدف مشاهدينا لرفع مستوى الجاهزيه
والاستعداد القتالي للقوات البحريه
السعوديه بما يعزز الامن البحري في
المنطقه الحمد لله رب العالمين نحتفل
اليوم بتسليم الدفعه الاخيره من مشروع
الزوارق السريعه
والذي تم تصنيع 50% من هذا المشروع في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بشراكه
استراتيجيه بين كل من شركتي الزامل
الخدمات البحريه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وشركه الفرنسيه
ومتابعه واشراف من الهيئه العامه للصناعات
العسكريه
من الدمام ينضم الينا الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه الزامل للخدمات البحريه المهندس
سفيان الزامل ساعه المهندس حياك الله معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض سعيدين
بانضمامك الينا في البدايه نريد ان نعرف
اكثر عن هذا المشروع مشروع توطين تصنيع
طبعا وتوطين هذه الزوارق الاعتراضيه
السريعه كيف بدات القصه الى اين وصلت
اليوم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اشكركم على
الاستضافه حياك الله القصه يا طويل العمر
بدانا حنا 1977 تقريبا بدانا العمل في
تشغيل السفن في شركه ارامكو السعوديه
واستمرينا بالعمل
في 2002 بدانا
بتصنيع السفن في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وصنعنا اول سفينه في المملكه في مجمع بناء
السفن في ميناء الدمام الان وصلنا الى
سبعين سفينه
بنيت في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لهذا الموضوع
2015 بدانا العمل مع شركه سي ام ان
الفرنسيه
رتبنا معاهم
سفيان طيب يبدو كل
اتفضل اتفضل اتفضل صوتك قطعت الصوره
2015 بدانا الترتيب مع شركه سي ام ان
والتخطيط
لشركه طبعا
الفرنسيه
لمحاوله ايجاد
الاشياء المطلوبه من القوات البحريه رتبنا
جميع المخططات قمنا بالتخ
طيط 2018 ارسلنا بعض الكوادر حوالي 50 شخص
الى فرنسا للتدريب على راس العمل على
اللحام
للالمنيوم لانه احنا كل الصناعات اللي قبل
كنا نصنعها كنا نصنعها السفن من حديد هذه
اول مره ندخل القطاع العسكري فصنعنا
دربنا الشباب هناك خمسين شاب ورجعوا
واخذوا التدريب ورجعوا 2019 بدانا بالبناء
وردنا اول سفينه
للقوات البحريه في 2020 في ظل جائحه
كورونا وكان عندنا تحديات كبيره بصراحه
لكن الحمد لله تفوقنا عليها اليوم
وردنا 18 زورق اعتراضي تم بناءهم في
السعوديه وحوضان عائمان وخمسه وثلاثين
رصيف بحري طيب يعني كل هذه السفن هذه
السفن الفرنسيه اللي هي اتش اس اي 32 نعم
كلها بنيت وصنعت في
السعوديه ثمانيه عشر هذه التي تتحدث عنها
نعم هي سابقه كانت تصنع في فرنسا وانت
نقلت المعرفه الى السعوديه من خلال خمسين
شخص اللي انتم ارسلتوهم ودربتوهم من 2018
لا ال 50 شخص نقلنا معرفه الحامل
الالمنيوم لكن التكنولوجيا ككل وطناها
كتصميم وكبناء للسعوديه لما بنينا 18
سفينه زائد تسعه الاخرين اللي قاعدين
نشتغل عليهم الان كيف
التواصل او او الدور الهيئه العامه
للصناعات العسكريه في في مثل هذه المشاريع
وتواصلكم انتم معهم والله تواصلنا ممتاز
جدا ولولا الله ثم الهيئه الوطنيه
للصناعات العسكريه كما قدرنا بصراحه اننا
نوصل
للي احنا وصلنا له والنجاح اللي صار يعني
ضمن رؤيه 2030 ان يكون 50% من الانفاق
العسكري يصرف في السعوديه والهيئه مشكوره
وضعت التشريعات اللازمه لالزام التوطين
ووضع الاليات لنقل التكنولوجيا والتصاميم
وبناء السفن والقطاع العسكري عموما
ودعمونا كثير في تدليل العقوبات بصراحه
يعني كانوا مشهورين جدا انه يمتاز نجحنا
خليني اسال يعني اي احد بيقرا عن هذا
الخبر
اكيد حيتبادر الى ذهنه سؤال انه وش
الادوار اللي تقوم فيها هذه السفن هل هي
قتاليه هل هي دفاعيه كيف طريقه ايضا عملها
هذه السفن هذي من افضل يعني اذا ما هي
افضل زورق اعتراضي في العالم
زورق اعتراضي سريع طوله 32 متر مجهز ببعض
الاسلحه
لانه زي ما انت عارف الحدود السعوديه
عندنا الشرق والغرب حدود استراتيجيه كبيره
جدا كلها فمحتاجين نوعيه الزوارق السريعه
هي زوارق اعتراضيه سريعه لحمايه الحدود
وحمايه الوطن اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الدمام
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه الزامل لخدمات
البحريه المهندس سفيان الزامل
اذا استكملت السعوديه مشروعه تصنيعي
وتوطين منظومه الزوارق الاعتراضيه السريعه
اتش اس اي 32 الذي ياتي ضمن اهداف
السعوديه بتوطين ما يزيد عن 50 في المئه
من اجمال الانفاق الحكومي على المعدات
والخدمات العسكريه بحلول 20 30 الزورق
للاعتراضي مشاهدي سريع اتش اس اس اي 32
يمكنه القيام بعملياته البحريه مع
المروحيات الزورق الذي يبلغ طوله 32 مترا
وبعرض سبعه امتار يمكنه الابحار بسرعه تصل
الى 98 كيلو مترا في الساعه كما يمكن لهذا
النوع من الزوارق مشاهدينا السريعه
استيعاب طاقم مكون من 12 فردا الزورق
السريع اتش اس اي 32 مجهزون بانظمه متطوره
مثل رادارات البحث اضافه الى اجهزه
استشعار بص ريه كهربائيه كما تم تسليحه
برشاش من عيار 20 ملي مترا بالاضافه الى
مدفعين يغطيان زاويه
360 درجه ويمكن لهذا الزورق مشاهدينا
تنفيذ العمليات العسكريه البحريه اضافه
الى القيام بعمليات البحث والانقاذ وحمايه
السفن ومكافحه القرصنه
تعتزم جامعه كاوست غرب السعوديه بدات
تنفيذ مبادره الاحياء الشعب المرجانيه في
البحر الاحمر حيث ستكون جزيره شوشه
والواقع في محيط شمال اليوم اولى المواقع
التي سيتم تنفيذ المبادره فيها اعلانو
كاوس جاء خلال منتدى مفتوح للبحث العلمي
نظمته الجامعه وناقش خلاله المشاركين
والخبراء المحليين والدوليين عده مواضيع
في مجالات الطاقه والمياه والبيئه والغذاء
بالاضافه الى المجالات الرقميه
راح نبدا نحي شعار المرجانيه حوالين جزيره
شوشه في منطقه مساحتها تقريبا تساوي 180
ملعب كره قدم فتكون منطقه جدا كبيره او
عندنا في المبادره كذا عنصر رئيسي عندنا
الحضانه المرجانيه البريه حتكون قادره على
انتاج 400 الف مرجان في السنه وحيكون
عندنا الحضانه المرجانيه المائيه
حتكون في نفس الشعار المرجانيه حوالينا
جزيره تكون قادر على الانتاج في السنه
وحيكون عندنا مركز ابحاث في جزيره نفسها
بالاضافه ان هو حيكون اداه مفتوحه لاي احد
من انحاء العالم وطلبه علماء باحثين انهم
يسبحوا يغوص افتراضيا حوالين الجزيره
باستخدام المارين
تقوم جمعيه ارفا المتخصصه بدعم مرضى
التصلب العصبي المتعدد بتقديم عدد كبير من
ورش العمل والدورات التدريبيه لمساعده
المصابين في تجاوز ازمتهم الصحيه نوفل
عبيدي احدى هؤلاء المستفيدات حيث ساهم
الفن التشكيلي في تحسن حالتها الصحيه زميل
عبد الرحمن العصيمي التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
رغم اصابتها بمرض التصلب العصبي المتعدد
خاضت نوف العبيدي تحدي تعلم الرسم ودخول
عالم الفن التشكيلي عله يساعدها في تجاوز
ازمتها الصحيه عبر دخول ورشه عمل مكثفه
استطاعت بعدها من بيع احدى لوحاتها في
معرض فني بمدينه الخبر شرق السعوديه اقبال
الناس كم مره حلو تشجيعهم مساهمتهم دعمهم
لنا يعني زي ما انت شايفه اللوحه
كان شيء جميل وتجربه رائعه
واكيد في استمراريه ومواصلات انا انصح اي
اي شخص سواء مصاب وغير مصاب بالفن للفن
يعني جميل جدا وتفريغ طاقه سلبيه وممتع
نوف احدى المستفيدات من انشطه جمعيه ارفا
المتخصصه بدعم مرضى التصلب العصبي المتعدد
حيث تضم هذه الجمعيه اكثر من الف
وثلاثمائه
وثلاثه متطوعا ومتطوعا ويبلغ عدد
المستفيدين من الجمعيه حوالي
741 مستفيدا وتمكنت الجمعيه منذ انطلاقها
توفير اكثر من
373 جهاز طبيا لمساعده المرضى لحمل
الغالبيه المرضى يعني يتوجهون لهذا
الاتجاه تتحسن عندهم اعراض الاعراض
النفسيه او السيكولوجيه وما نحتاج ان نلجا
للادويه النفسيه في في حالتهم فمن هذا
المنطلق بدات فكره انه نعمل ورش وندخل
موضوع الرسم لهذا المرضى
تشير الارقام الى ان عدد المصابين بمرض
التصلب العصبي المتعدد يبلغ نحو عشره الاف
مصاب بحسب وزاره الصحه السعوديه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه الخبر العربيه
[موسيقى]
يقدم متحف الشفاء في جده غرب السعوديه
الجزائريه تجربه مختلفه حيث يعد الاول في
رصد اسهامات العلماء المسلمين في نهضه
الطب ينقسم المتحف الى تسعه اقسام رئيسيه
هي طب النبوي والترجمه والتاليف والعدوى
وبراعه التشخيص كذلك ايضا طب العيون
والتشريح وعلم وظائف الاعصاب وطب النساء
والولاده والصيدله والجراحه كما ان لكل
قسم في المعرض استعراض لمساهمات العلماء
المسلمين في الطب واستعراض العشرات من
مخطوطاتهم الطبيه النادره وكتبهم وغيرها
ايضا من المقتنيات
ومن داخل اول متحف طبي انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سعود الخلف سعود مساء الخير حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
يعني نريد ان تتجول ان نرى هذا المتحف
الطبي الذي يقام لاول مره اعتقد ايضا انه
اقدم متحف لطب الاسنان في السعوديه
هو اول متحف من نوعه مهتم بالعلوم الطبيه
وعلوم الاستشفاء والجراحه في العالم
الاسلامي بيحوي الكثير من الاقسام
يعني بزور المتحف راح ينبهر بما يجد من
جماليات في هذا المتحف طبعا يركز ايضا على
اربعه من اشهر العلماء المسلمين في مجال
الطب اللي هم ابو بكر الرازي ابن النفيس
ابو القاسم الزهراوي وابن سينا
[موسيقى]
واثرهم في تطوير الطب من ذاك الزمن حتى
وقتنا الحالي في كثير من التفاصيل ينايف
ولكن اسمح لي انه يكون معي دكتور محمد
الكربي وهو المشرف العام على المتحف حتى
يعطينا نبدا ولو بشكل سريع عن ما يحويه من
مقتنيات اثريه جميله يعطيك العافيه دكتور
هذا المتحف الجميل ناخذ نبدا سريعه عن
المتحف الله يعطيك العافيه اشكرك زر الشكر
على هذه التغطيه الاولى بصراحه يعني طالما
غطته مت السابقه اللي سويتها مؤسسه المداد
متحف المكتئين متحف الاسلاميه هذا هو
المتحف الثالث المتحف الثالث يعني يتناول
تاريخ المسلمين اسهامات المسلمين في تسعه
اقسام تسعه اقسام هذه هذه الجوانب اللي
كان للمسلمين اثر كبير جدا في تطويرها
ونهضتها من مثلا يعني طب النساء والولاده
طب الجراحه الاطفال العدوى والوباء اضافه
الى الاربعه المنصات الرئيسيه اللي هي
تتناول الاربع العلماء اللي انت ذكرتهم
حناخذ الجوله والكاميرا معانا تتجول ونشوف
نبدا بقسم الجراحه وكلمنا على الادوات
الموجوده في دكتور طيب ادوات الجراحيه
طبعا احنا هنا نسلط الضوء على العالم ابو
القاسم الزهراوي ابو القاسم الزهراوي
يعتبر من العلماء اللي وضعوا اسس الجراحه
حتى يسمى عند الغرب ابي ابي الجراحه
الجراحه كانت على ايام ابو القاسم
الزهراوي هي كانت مهنه مهنه ممتحنه يعني
كانت مهنه الحلاقين والفسادين والحجامين
فكان الطبيب يترفع عن الجراحه امانه
معلومه اي والله ابو القاسم الزهراوي هو
اول من وضع العلوم الصحيحه وسوى يعني
رسومات لقرابه 200 اداه جراحيه من تفكيره
بالكامل هذا
جراحيه اللي يمكن للطبيب استخدامها لعلاج
الكثير من الامراض هذه الادوات حقيقيه ومن
زمن الزهراوي نعم هذه الادوات حتى تسبق
احيانا الزهراوي وفي على زمن الزهراوي وفي
ادوات حتى البعض يراها ادوات يعني انصحها
القول بشعه او كيف الواحد ممكن يستخدمها
ولكن هي ادوات تستخدمه دكتور تمر وعسل
وزيت وحبه سوداء يا فؤاد
طبعا الفكره انه احنا في هذا المتحف تاون
نتناول تاريخ الطب والاستشفاء عند
المسلمين حتى من اثناء من النقر الاسلام
طب العرب وعلى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اوصى باستخدام بعض الادوات بعض الاعشاب
الطبيه والاغذيه للاستشفاء مثل العسل لفت
انتباهي شغله انه موجوده هنا في المتحف
حافظه التمائم هذه وش هي حافظه التهامي
سعود سعود الملفت للانتباه اكثر من الوقت
باستخدام يعني بعض المصاحف الصغيره او
الاوراق المكتوب عليها ايات قرانيه
وموضوع داخل حافظات من احنا احنا كان ودنا
ناخذ وقت اطول لانه المتحف بصراحه
الكثير من الوقت يا سعود لما يحويه من
اقسام خطيره انا اشكرك جزيلا شكرا
الكريم
لك سعود الخلف مراسل العربيه اذا مشاهدينا
الكرام قبل قليل تابعنا في العاجل الاسفل
الشاشه اعلام اوكرانيا يتحدث عن وقوع
انفجار عنيف هزاع العاصمه الاوكرانيه
من هناك معنى الصحه في محمد الباب ومحمد
مرحبا بك ماذا لديك معلومات حول هذا
الانفجار الذي هز العاصمه كيف
نعم يعني قبل حوالي 20 دقيقه هزا انفجار
منطقه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وبحسب في تلك
الاسبوع عمده لان حريق شابه في احد
الابنيه وبعد الحريق يعني انفجرت احدى
اسطوانات الغاز او الاكسجين في هذا المبنى
من ما سبب او كان صوت الانفجار عنيف جدا
وشبح حريقه كبير في هذه البنايه في هذا
يعني المبنى السكني وايضا تعمل الان فرق
الانقاذ وفرق الدفاع المدني على اتفاق
الحريق هي اطفاء الحريق والبحث عن سكوت
ضحايا في هذا المبنى الذي يعتبر مبنى سكني
لذلك وكما قال بطريق كوفي يعني
تويتر وعلى شبكه تيليجرام ان الانفجار هو
يعني غير متعلق باي عمليه عسكريه بل كان
يعني حادثه وتعتبر هذه الحادثه من الحوادث
المدنيه لذلك لا وجود لاي اعتداء عسكري او
او يعني عمل تخريبي بسبب هذا الانفجار
الذي كان وكما يتداول فيه التليجرام وفي
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه ان الصوت كان
انفجار كبير وعنيف في منطقه
لذلك ننتظر يعني بعد فتره ستتوضح الصوره
بشكل اوفر ولكن يعني تعليق حديث عن ضحايا
ومصابين محمد حتى الان
لحظه كما قال توجهت فرق الاطفاء وفرق
الاسعاف الى مكان وقوع هذا الانفجار او
هذا الحريق ولان هناك يعني سحابه دخان
كثيفه خرجت من هذا المبنى بعد سقوط بعد
صوت الانفجار الكثيف وبحسب يعني ما يتداول
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان هناك
حريقا شابه في البدايه ثم سمع صوت انفجار
كبير في منطقه
يعني هذا الانفجار لا علاقه له باي عمليه
عسكريه ربما روسيه او او عمل يعني من
مشابه يعني
للعمليات العسكريه ربما
الموجوده طبعا في الشرق الاوكراني والان
طبعا عمده كيف يتحدث عن اصابه شخص في
انفجار بمصنع في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
محمد كما نتابع الان اسفل الشاشه عمده كيف
يتحدث اذا عن اصابه شخص في انفجار
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كما ذكرت محمد
قبل قليل يبدو ان فعلا هذه
وهذا الصوت وهذا الانفجار العنيف الذي هز
العاصمه كيف لم يكن له علاقه باي عمليه
عسكريه ربما في العاصمه كيف اريد كذلك ان
اسال عن الحاله العامه في العاصمه كيف كيف
تبدو في تخوم ايضا العاصمه كيف ان كانت
هناك معلومات من تفاصيل ميدانيه جديده
محمد يعني
الحياه شبه طبيعيه يعني حركه السيارات
طبيعيه اليوم خاصه ان الطقس الى حد ما
يعني افضل من الايام الثلاثه الماضيه ولكن
يعني وضع اوكرانيا في هذه الايام هو وضع
ترقب خاصه ان اليوم يعني كان هناك بعض
المواقف من الرئيس وكان يعني ينتظر او
يترقب سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه ومعجم سكان
اوكرانيا يعني ينتظرون المرحله المقبله هل
ستكون تخفيف للعمليات العسكريه والقصف
الصاروخي الذي يطال بعض المدن الاوكرانيه
ولكن يعني في شرق اوكرانيا وبحسب يعني
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه الاشتباكات عنيفه
جدا وهناك هجوم كبير ومكثف ويتضاعف يوما
بعد يوم يتضاعف الهجوم على مدينه باخموت
الجيش الاوكراني اكد وفي يعني مداخله احد
الضباط الاوكرانيين المعروف باسم مليار
قال صباح هذا اليوم ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقاتل ولكنها تواجه صعوبات في الحصول على
الامداد العسكري والامداد اللوجستي وايضا
في الصمود لذلك كان هناك بعض القرارات من
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اليوم لتزويد
وامداد القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه
خاصه ان يعني التكثيف العسكري للقوات
الروسيه في تلك المنطقه وفي منطقه اخرى
منطقه ايضا هناك اشتباكات عنيفه وتحاول
القوات الروسيه التقدم والدخول والحصول
على اراضي جديده خاصه التي تعتبر نقطه
اساسيه للقوات الاوكرانيه في قصر مراكز
الجيش الروسي في محيط مدينه
الشكر من كيف الصحفي محمد الباب على كل
هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات فصل قصير نعود
بعده لاستكمال الرابع
اعلن رئيس هيئه الترفيه السعودي تركيا
للشيخ عن اقامه اكبر تجمع لصنع اله العود
من 13 دوله حول العالم وذلك بدا من التاسع
من مارس المقبل لمده ثلاثه ايام التجمع
الاكبر من نوعه حول العالم سيشهد مسابقات
بجوائز الكبرى يتجاوز اجماليها النصف
مليون ريال على 3 فئات من العازفين
المتسابقين
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تتهم اوكرانيا
بمحاوله استهداف مقاطعتين روسيتين
بالمسيره ليلا
المانيا تؤكد قلقها من برنامج ايران
النووي وتقول بان لا مبرره لنسبه التخصيب
الحاليه
الصناعات العسكريه السعوديه تعلن اكتمال
مشروع لتصنيع الزوارق الاعتراضيه السعوديه
وجامعه السعوديه تطرق اكبر مبادره لاحياء
الشعب المرجانيه في العالم
شكرا لكم لكرم اللطف المتابعه نهايه
الرابعه اعود والقاكم غدا في رعايه الله